この章のテーマは、生成AI時代の研究はどこへ向かうのかということでございます。
ここでキーワードになるのは分野差なんですね。
サブタイトルにある通り、使い方というのはですね、非常にまだ分かれているんですけども、
ただ研究を加速させるのはどうも事実のようだというのは言われています。
ただ、それだけでははっきりしなくてですね、
より中身も含めてですね、考える必要があるのかなというふうに思っています。
それでは実際に入っていきましょう。
まずですね、研究において生成AIを利用する局面っていろいろあるかと思うんですけども、
その中で便利なツールとして出てくるのはこのラグでございます。
検査拡張生成という機能で外部知識を引いてから答えるということですね。
例えば論文の一覧表みたいなものを全部突っ込んで、
それをノートブックエリアムで出すみたいなことが出てきます。
これはですね、AIの丸暗記ではなくてですね、
参照できるものを引いて答える仕組みですし、
出典を提示するという機能もありますので、
非常に裏取りがしやすかったりします。
自分の資料にですね、紐付けて応答できたりするので、
この点はですね、かなり進んでいくのかなというふうに思います。
皆さん、ジェミリフォーサイエンスというのは聞いたことありますか?
例えばですね、こういうふうにGoogleさんの方などでプレイスリースが出ていまして、
AI自体の研究をひりひらくツールですよ、みたいなのが出てくると。
この中で3つの機能が出ているんですけども、
このHypothesis Generationのところ、
交際に基盤に書いていますけども、
これにいろんなですね、AIエージェントによって考えられるよ、みたいな話もあったりします。
それからですね、計算的な発見機能みたいなのがあったりすると書いてあるんですけども、
この3番目のところにですね、リテラジャーインサイトってあるんですね。
ノートブックエリアムと呼ばれるような、こういうふうなノートブックを作る機能がありますけど、
それをもとにですね、いろいろと研究が分かりやすくなるんじゃないの、みたいなものを作っているようです。
いわゆる研究に特化したノートブックエリアムみたいなのがあるようなんですよね。
ただしですね、出店の絶望みたいなところが、
完璧にゼロが誘うでもなかったりとかですね、
あとニュアンスが合わないことも起きたりするので、
その手間は十分に注意してもらえればと思います。
対応の文献からですね、何かを引いて考えるみたいなところは、
AIがかなりうまくなっているよっていうのをちょっとご理解ください。
続いてですね、コーディングとかエージェントみたいなところですね。
さっきの前半戦にもありましたけど、
あと、ジェミリー・フォーサイエンスの前半、こっち側ですね、こういうところ、
こういうところっていうのは、エージェントがかなり来ているわけでございます。
有名になったのはですね、オープンエアのコーデックスなんとかで有名になったかと思います。
例えば、自然原稿のCで〇〇を解析するコードを書いているとですね、
自動的にコード作成、テスト実行、それからうまくいくまでっていうのを
ずっと事実的にループを回して、コードを完成させていくみたいなことです。
その設計とかですね、最終検証というのは人がしないといけないんですけども、
少なくともここが自動化できるという点で非常に便利だったりします。
現状はですね、クロードコードをはじめとする
アントロピックのAIなども、この点は強みとしていまして、
オープンAIとアントロピックとかなり戦っているというのが実際の現状でございます。
例えばコーディングに関してですけども、自然原稿からコードを生成するというのはかなり容易になりました。
コードというのはですね、比較的正解不正解というのは分かりやすいので、
実際に改善したりするということですね。
作業がかなり高度化しているのが現状です。
ただし、要注意としてですね、動くことイコール結果足しようとはないので、
あくまで監視というのはやっていきましょうね。
Human in the loopという形で、例えばGoogleさんとかであれば、
AIの回答する前に、人が一回確認する手順を必要にした設計にしたりします。
あとHuman in the loopというのもありますよね。
監視中心で必要なときだけ介入するということで、
ループはAIで閉じてしまうんだけど、
人がですね、適切にオブタイムをするということです。
こういう形でですね、いろんな発展としてですね、
エージェントラグなんてものが使われていると。
ただ最終検証であったりとかですね、
一番最初の設計の部分というのは、
一ままで握っているなという印象があります。
皆さん、疑問に思ったことありませんか。
AIで研究が加速するのかということです。
これはですね、ワイヤリーの論文のちょっと有名な調査があって、
これをぜひ読んでいただきたいんですけど、
メアドとかを登録すれば確かに落ちてくるんですが、
その中にですね、こういうのがあります。
いろんな研究者に聞きましたよと。
だいたい2000人くらいでしたかね。
Aって研究どう変えるみたいなところでですね、
研究の効率化というのはものすごく上がるんだと、
85%が効率向上を実感したというふうに言われています。
量的な研究と質的な研究で、量的な部分ですね、
コンティノブは77%、質的な部分は73%ということで、
かなりの比率があってですね、
研究が出版の利用がですね、
もう6割ぐらいに来たということでございます。
復旧するだろうと、もっともっと必要になってくるだろうというのは、
多くの人が思っているんですけども、
一方で懸念というのがどんどん上昇していてですね、
特にガイドライン不足、
この研究を使っているのかどうか分からないから、
というところがおかげになっているようです。
あと懸念事項としてもですね、
不正確だったり、ハルシネーションの懸念だったり、
あるいは下にあるようなですね、
プライバシーの懸念だったりということで、
何らか懸念があるよと言っている人は、
全体の87%になるという結果になっています。
なので、皆さんですね、
多くの研究者が、
AIで研究が加速しそうだ、
効率的になったと感じているけども、
懸念が多いということでなっています。
先ほどもいろんなツールをお知らせしましたが、
いろんな具体例があります。
例えば、自然科学でですね、
アルファホールドという形で、
タンパク質関係ですかね、
生命系の研究で300万人以上の研究者を、
例えばGoogleは支援しているというのがあったりします。
ジェミニフォーサイエンスの機能を使うことによってですね、
ゲノム解析が相当短くなったとか、
あるいはオープンエアですね、
以前はO3とかでそういった論文をやられていましたけど、
今の推論系モデルでですね、
かなり数学だとか、
あるいは物理の理論系の問題が解かれているというのは、
非常に驚くべきことでございます。
この流れはですね、
自然科学だけがとどまらないんですね。
自然科学というのは比較的真理というかですね、
答えが一つになる場合が多いので、
AIとの相性はですね、
良いのかなと思うんですけど、
実は社会系でもかなり生きていると。
例えばオープンエアもですね、
ガブリエルということで、
指摘データから数字を取り出す、
社会科学向けのAIを作ってあったりとか、
あるいはアンストロピックもですね、
AIチャットボットの利用研究を社会科学のですね、
学者さんに対して行っていて、
8割がチャットボットを使っていたよとかですね、
クロードコードを使っていたのに、
2割しかいなかったよみたいな感じの研究も行っていたりするようです。
このようにAIの普及の差というのがですね、
研究の格差を生むリスクが近年生まれてきているのかなという印象ではあります。
先ほどもですね、
アンストロピックのこの調査を言いましたけれども、
定量系のですね、社会科学者、
この人数に調査して、
どうなっているかと調べましたよと言われています。
広がる利用格差はというところなんですけれども、
多くの人がAIチャットボットを利用していましたよとかいうことで出ています。
面白いことにですね、
PhDの学生から実際のですね、
教授までどの年齢層をどんだけ使っていたかみたいなデータが乗っかっていて、
あとコーディングエージェント、
いわゆるクロードコードみたいなものを使っている人が大体2割ですよと。
クロードコードはですね、
うち86%の人が使っていますよと言われていました。
最も多い用途は分析コード生成でしたよ。
文章作成に使わないような3分の違いでしたよみたいなですね、
そういうコーディングエージェントに関する調査が行われていたようです。
面白いことにですね、
コーディングエージェントはトップ25代わゆる利用率が1.4倍ということで、
そうした大学しか契約していないというか、
大学で無料で使えないからかもしれないですけど、
利用率が高くなっていますよと言われていました。
コーディングエージェントを使っている人についてですね、
使っていない人と比べたところ、
生産性の変化があって、
研究の着手時点ではですね、
プラス10ポイント、
ワーキングペーパーで75ポイントもありましたよということで、
非常に大きな差が出ていました。
ジャーナル投稿は有利さがないと言われています。
88%が生産性の向上を実感というところですね。
非常に多くの人が生産性向上を実感しているんですけども、
一方でですね、
これによって論文がパンクするんじゃないかとかですね、
分野全体の悪影響があるのではないかと心配している人が多いようです。
ということで、便利さは実感されつつですけども、
普及することによる格差というのがあったり、
あるいは活用リテラシーの格差があったりというのがですね、
今度は研究の成果についての格差につながり得るんじゃないかということが
心配されているところでございます。
一方でですね、
このようにAIの状況というのがあるわけですけど、
これってあくまでクロードコードとかですね、
そういうコーディングエージェントの売り込みみたいな問題なわけですよ。
だってアンストロピック自体が調査しているわけですから、
なので、そこら辺はちょっと、
何ですかね、
斜めから見た方がいいのかなという論文ではあるんですけども、
現状こうなっているということでなっていましたと。
あと、あえて言えばですね、
使わないという選択を意図的に行うというのも正しいと思うんですよね。
この分野の範囲の、
この範囲では使わないよというのをきちんと持っておくというのは重要かとなと思いました。
定量の人なので、
定性の人になるとまた全然状況が変わると思いますので、
ちょっと、
そういう話題提供でございます。
分野差とか個人差があるよということなんですけども、
これ一律の正解がですね、実はないと思います。
例えば、情報系の人というのは、
もう早いAIで論文がりがり書いてですね、
赤読み投稿していくというのは普通になっていると思うんですよね。
医学系とか看護系のような実践系の部分も、
かなりAIの利用というのが良いというふうに認められているんじゃないでしょうか。
一方で、実験系とかだとどうですかね。
なんか体温データを扱うところはいいけど、
実際に論文を書くのは人みたいなところが残っていますよね。
事務系だとどうですかね。
作品自体が重要だとか、
その着眼点が重要だというところでAIを使ったら、
多分研究として成り立たなくなる部分ってあると思うんですよね。
だから、課題となってくるのはですね、
自分の部下の作法というのをしっかり確認してみてください。
それから、学会、論文誌、指導教員、方針を確認することも重視してください。
その上ですね、自分がどうAIで書かれるのかというのを
言葉にして必要があるのかなと思います。
下の方に3パネルありますが、
それぞれの系統でどんなふうなAI利用があるかみたいなことを
ちょっと僕が知っている範囲で書いたものでございます。
なのでですね、こうした大雑把な傾向があるんですけども、
皆さんご自身がどう考えるかというのを書き上げていくというのが
この授業での重要なことでございます。
ということでですね、第8章でしたけども、
加速させる点としてですね、
例えばラグとかエージェントみたいなところが
結構最近ではもてはらせてますよということを触れました。
その上で懸念点というのがあるよ、
しかも分野差があるよということをお伝えしたところでございます。
加速するというかですね、
効率化できるだろうと多くの研究者が考えているようですが、
それが本当に良いのかどうか、
あるいはですね、
その分野によっても使っていいのかどうかが変わると。
なので、自分の言葉でですね、
どうAIを研究によってかかっていくかを
考えていきましょうというのが、
この10のキーポイントになるということでございます。
では、この動画を終わります。
ご視聴ありがとうございました。